Talking to you about Houdini, and there is
so much to cover so I will go right into it.
I love this meme.
When I was a pup, I had one toy and it was
sick.
This is like writing CSS 15 years ago, where
we didn't have the technology we have today,
we have custom properties, there is so much
at our hands, and it makes writing styles
for the web such a joy.
CSS still has its downfalls and challenges,
right?
Let's talk about form styling.
Why?
Why can't we style forms in 2019?
If you're familiar with W3 schools, an education
site that shows you basic ways to write web
for the code, and so I saw this custom dropdown
there and I thought, ""Oh, cool.""
The steps we've got is we've got HTML, we
are adding CSS - fine - there's like some
studio elements there, and then I scroll down
and it's [sound problem].
Still today, it's frustrating because I like
to separate my logic and my styling.
You can't do it on the web.
We can make gradients on the web, and they're
cool, dynamic, you can create a comma-separated
list of values - live on page - you can adjust
these things.
You can layer them.
So it becomes this really great tool when
you're creating filter effects on images.
I using this on the web.
You can't read ... gradients yet.
The top point, they go round the centre and
to to that point.
If we wanted to create ... if we wanted to
create a continuous gradient we would create
the colour for the first and last value and
create it there.
If we look at ""can I use"", we can see that
the gradients are not well stored, so we can't
use those on the web.
Gradients are something that doesn't currently
exist in CSS.
Right here, I have an example where I have
a div, and, when I hover it, I'm converting
from red to blue.
So that is what I'm trying to do inside this
gradient.
I'm setting it to go to right and from red
to blue, and then transferring to deep pink.
When I hover on this gradient, this div, it's
not able to transition that value, and we
will get into it a little bit later.
Not able to do it on the web.
Custom borders are something that you can
kind of on the web.
We have a border digital property which is
cool but it's limited.
If you wanted to do something like a corner
shape which would mask your image as well
as apply a border shape on that element, this
is not something that you can do, and this
is 200013 spec who tried to push this forward
and it never really got into browsers - sad.
But
there's Houdini?
If you haven't heard of Houdini, it's really,
really cool.
It's basically a low-level API-for-CSS, and
more accurately, it's a series of APIs that
give developers access to the CSS object model,
and it allows us to tell the browser how we
want it to read our CSS code.
So, this is kind of what happens now?
If you want to style something on the web
that doesn't currently exist as a CSS property
and value pair that you can write in CSS,
you have to write a JavaScript polyfill for
it.
So, your browser goes through this parser
set and reads the DOM and the CSS object model,
and then you have to do that all over again
with the JavaScript polyfill because you're
reapplying the styles to the page after it's
already loaded ones.
But with Houdini we can apply the styles directly
to the CSS, so we have so much power as developers
now, because we can tell the browser at that
CSS step what it should be doing when it is
reading our code.
Exciting.
So while it takes a while for specs to get
implemented in browsers, that is like this
big dog here taking its time, that's a good
thing, we don't want the browser to implement
anything.
If you wanted a feature that doesn't currently
exist, you can be like this pupper zooming
by creating your own tech, CSS polyfills,
creating JavaScript to do it, and it exists
in the browser.
Pretty cool.
The best resource for this right now is Houdini
ready yet - we have all the browsers agreed
that implement the spec, as well as the W3
specs you can go and read.
The state of ""can I use?
"" For Houdini.
It's very much a work in progress.
The most supported APIs are the paint API
and the typed object model, and so because
we have limited time, that's what we are going
to focus on here today.
So let's start with the typed object model.
The typed object model allows us to have more
semantic CSS parsing.
What does that mean?
Right now, it has to go through the whole
string-based Regex parsing, and that is slow,
it's looking for an ID, property, class, or
a specific key word in that string which is
like the dot here, and the string from that
dot until that open curly brace, then looking
for a property value, a colon, a value, a
unit, a semicolon, making sure those are accurate
values and they work properly.
This can get really messy really fast, and
it's just so much slower than having some
structured data, so the typed object model
supplies that structured model.
I get a value like height and we return a
CSS unit value which is this object that returns
a value and a unit, so this is a lot more
semantic and so therefore it makes it faster
to read through that CSS.
And so here I'm doing this, I have a box,
it has width and height.
We can get properties from computer style-out
and you can set properties, so do attributes,
property, and then I could specify css.number
giving it a type, and then it's going to update
and a that, and, when we do that again, we
see we're getting our parsing.
If you look at this in DevTools, you will
get the CSS unit value object where you have
that unit and value separated out.
That leads me to the property and the values
API.
Have any of you used custom properties right
now?
That's 30 per cent of you.
Custom properties are really great because
they're actual dynamic CSS variables that
we have not browser.
Unlike Sass where you have a static variable
that you're using which is going to port out
to some value, here, you can actually update
these in JavaScript.
You can separate your logic and your styling
again because you can keep the style part
in CSS and do the logic to change that value
inside of your JavaScript, and then pass it,
and super dynamic and cool, so you get a name
and a value with your basic custom properties,
but with the properties and values API, you
get so much more than that.
You can specify a name for it, a syntax for
it, and an initial value definition, and,
if it isn't going to inherit from its parent.
Let's look at the example again of the gradient.
We have our box, and I have a colour, so it
is custom property, and I'm transitioning
from that colour.
I'm specifying the transition's going to be
one second long, and on hover, it's going
to turn blue.
So, again, still not getting an interaction
here.
It should take one second to register that
colour.
We can call this whatever we want.
I have colour-stop, the syntax is colour,
and specifying that syntax.
I'm not going to inherit the initial value
which will be transparent.
The as I update this to colour-stop, update
this value here, also to colour-stop, and
I update the transition to colour-stop, if
I create the hover to match all of those and
run this, it's going to slowly fade into the
blue.
[Applause].
I love visual demos!
It's just like, wow.
I typed one thing, registered property, there's
so much meeting behind that property now.
It's not just a string value.
There's actual meaning for the browser to
understand interpolation between to these
these two values.
The other thing about custom properties is
that you can set initial, fallback values.
I have to registered properties, colour primary
and secondary.
If you look at the CSS, we are transitioning
from colour primary to secondary on hover.
We are getting that one-second transition,
if you notice, I'm not actually specifying
that custom property, that variable inside
of the CSS here.
I don't have to do that because I've registered
it in the CSS registered property.
I can update colour primary.
I can do colour primary red, and then if I
run this, it will update to red.
There's no problem there.
We can always update it.
If I don't have a fall here, if I have a false
value like 23, it will always fall back to
the blue-violet.
Let me show you what happens if I don't register
a custom property, there's an invalid colour
in the background, I run this, it falls back
to transparent.
The best thing about CSS is when there is
a false line, it doesn't crash your programme,
it just ignores that line so you can continue
living your life.
But it's something we can now look forward
to with this sort of air channelling and type-checking
for CSS.
And so this is kind of like having typed CSS
variables, and I think that's great for CSS
systems, design systems, making sure that
everything is super cohesive, and aligned
when you're building for the web with CSS,
with your team.
So, now I want to talk about the paint worklet.
If you've heard of service workers and web
workers kind of works the same in that it
is a layer between your - it pre renders assets
and push notifications because they live in
the in-between.
When you open the website, you register the
worklet on your website, so you can always
access that, even if your network is offline.
So, if we are registering our worklets, working
with the paints worklets, what we do in JavaScript
is register that type.
We give it a name.
I'm using a class here here.
You can put it in there.
In HTML, we need to ... to add it to the page,
and then you call what your naming register
paint, and then the CSS, you would specify
that work clip by name, so I called it ""fun""
in this example and I would be able to background-paint
fun.
Is this JavaScript and CSS?
Yes.
So let's take a look at this little example
that I made.
It's just some text, and what I'm doing is
I wrote this little Rainbow worklet where
I'm going top left to bottom right and adjusting
the size with these pixel values.
Then in the HTML, I'm adding the worklet to
the CSS, and then the style, the way that
I get to use it is by setting the background
image.
You can set a border image, use this in any
way you want.
It's one line of code to get all of those
effects in CSS.
Separate those concerns.
Here's our conig gradient again.
You can write Polly files.
Right now, there is a polyfill.
This polyfill where writing out this worklet
to allow for gradients, and you can send in
context geometry, properties, and argument.
So sending in those arguments allows us to
in the CSS type in here ""red"" and then we
can run this, and, in the browser, we get
what we saw before with that gradient is now
a full circle.
This is pretty cool.
The feature syntax is going to allow for us
this use these in variables where we can do
background gradient and right now we have
the syntax.
Again, this is experimental.
This is like extending the web.
That's really cool.
You're extending the web with CSS.
I work on material design now.
We provide a platform for developers to create
their own customised themes, and that includes
colour, topic, and also includes shape, and
this example is one of the samples called
Shine, where we have this angular shape.
These are the two things that we have as shape
sort of specs, and so rounded corner is one,
and you can definitely do that on the web,
but a cut corner is not something that we
can do on the web yet.
Like I showed earlier, that corner shape spec
never really got put into the browser.
But, we can sort of work around this.
You can create a CSS Houdini paint worklet,
and this is one that I made to just specify
the different corner radiuses, paint style
to be outlined, or filled, and you can just
start really to play and get a really good
feel for this.
You can use masking as well as background.
Remember the examples I was using showing
background.
When you use WebKit mask image, you specify
what you're doing at your mask for any elements,
and then I combine these techniques to recreate
these materials buttons but with the notches
here.
These are the original ones, and a big challenge
here was containing that ripple effect when
you hovered, so I used a mixture of background
and mask when I was creating in notch corners
worklet and applying it in the CSS to these
outlined buttons and filled buttons.
So you could take existing infrastructure
and progressively enhance it because you can
use that support, if you're using background,
it will just fall back to the previous line
in CSS.
And this is the way that we can integrate
it into our UIs now.
So, let's make some magic.
I'm going to do a live demo here.
Wish me luck.
Warnings: this is experimental, so have web
platform features enabled.
Also, you must be using ACDVS or localhost
because this lives outside of your page and
it's for security.
I hope this works.
So, let's start with a canvas.
I have a canvas here that I've set up, and
so it's just giving it a width and height.
I'm going to zoom in here so you could see
this a little better.
Inside of my JavaScript I'm having a random
function, setting up the canvas, giving parameters
for a sparkle, height, width of weight, and
position.
It's going to randomise the height, width,
and weight that have, randomise the position
of that.
We will set the colour, and then we are going
to paint this.
That's why every time I refresh, I'm going
to get a random sparkle.
We don't want one sparkle, we want probably
multiple sparkles.
Let's set 30 sparkles.
We are creating a loop here to loop through
and apply the sparkles.
Once this reloads, we have all the sparkles
- 30, that's a good start.
I feel like this colour yellow is a bit too
similar here, so we can use HSL values to
get a really saturated value, so I'm doing
a random between 90 and 100.
Hue is going to be the yellow/orange range,
and light is the thing that changes the most,
so I can get rid of our colour, so we have
this canvas, but I want to convert that now
into a paint worklet, right?
Let's get rid of all this.
Let's use something we're all familiar with,
and this is .... this is the Codepen for the
X?
Did you know you can change it?
The main thing here is that the tiles keep
their positions.
I will show you what that looks like here.
If I zoom out all the way, you can see that
this is the layout for the X up there, and
we're going to try to make some Houdini magic
work in that X.
So, what we need to do now since BBC got rid
of the canvas in the HTML is get rid of the
canvas in the JavaScript since we're not using
in stuff any more, and we have to start writing
a worklet.
Let's do that.
Let's do a type-check so we can see if type
of register paint is not equal to unde fined,
then we will create a class, create a class
call ""sparkle"".
And then inside of that, we want to use paint.
We're going to get the context and the size
of the div that we want to apply this to.
From there, we want to put this in here.
All of this we did, we created those sparkles
and place those inside here.
Now I have the beginning of a worklet but
we have to register it.
Let's go right outside of our statement where
we are checking to see if this is even supported,
and we will do a register paint, and we will
do sparkles as the name of it, and we have
to call that class sparkles.
So what we have to do now is make sure that
we are getting the size and height, not from
the canvas but from the element, so we have
to update that to size.
We have to to make sure that we are going
in here calling this JavaScript code, and
the way to do that inside of Codepen is use
your pen ID.
It's a little hackie.
I have to register this script.
I'm going
to do css.paint.worklet.module.
It's going to listening to this file in theory.
I'm going to save that.
Inside of our tile which is every single one
of the tiles, I'm going to do a background
paint sparkles.
And if this all worked out, we will see some
sparkles.
Sometimes, I have to refresh for it to work.
Oh, no!
What happened?
Okay.
Let's go through this.
All right, registered our worklet.
It has a name.
We are adding it to the HTML with this script.
The CSS paint worklet.
And we are applying this to our tile with
the name that we called for the time.
Well, this is not working, so, we're just
going to do this inside of another little
starter.
I will show you what this looks like.
We have a back-up!
[Applause].
Darn, I wished that worked so much.
That would have been so cool!
[Applause].
So you can play with these slides.
You can play with that Codepen which is really,
really cool.
What I did next was I got these input properties,
so I'm pulling in the input properties from
our document here where I'm creating a custom
property called ""sparkle num"" I'm animating
a key frame called sparkle, and I'm pulling
in the values and updating those and using
that as my animation.
Since this is not a registered property, it's
not going to interplate those values that
you want to - it's not going to return to
that every time.
A thing I learned yesterday.
So that is what that looks like, but remember
when I mentioned that this was truly JavaScript
in CSS?
So who created houdini.rocks, he created this
worklet that just evaluates a custom property,
so you can basically in your CSS put all of
this code and then you can apply the background
paint inside of your CSS.
It's super, super meta, but you're writing
your JavaScript and I thought you might like
to apply it.
I thought you might like that.
[Applause].
Thank you.
So there are some caveats to this approach,
and that is that it is semicolon sensitive.
Also, your variables must be there in instantiation,
they're not dynamic, so you can't get those
static properties and apply those here.
You have to have it all in one place.
I would love it if that could be its own custom
property that you include inside of your elements
but you can't do that right now.
You have to make sure that it is all in one
place if you do that method.
Now I want to talk about something extra.
Extra.css
is a little library I've been working on that
allows you to use Houdini today in your own
applications.
This is a CSS Houdini paint API library for
to make the making your sites a little more
Extra.
What we can do here is play with all of these
different things like the sparkle demo, you
can change the number of sparkles.. you can
make them bigger by changing the width variants,
the height variants, the weight to make them
thicker, you can create this scallop border,
give it any colour you want, you can play
with the weight of that, so you can adjust
that here.
Why have one underline when you can have many
underlines?
So, we have super underline.
You can adjust the number of underlines, the
spread of those underlines, the weight of
those underlines, and just have a little fun
playing with that.
There's a cross-out, so you can adjust this
colour too, you can change the weights of
this cross-out, and then confetti, because
who doesn't like confetti?
Confetti is a fun little thing to add to any
website.
Here, you have control over what that looks
like.
The way to use it is you can use this right
now by setting it up with one CDN listening,
so inside of the HTML, this example, I'm going
to close that result.
What I'm doing is we're just including the
worklet as a file, shout-out to my first contributor
working on this yesterday.
Yay.
So here you could include your script, and
then inside of your CSS, you can set properties
if you want to override them, or you can just
use background paint, and it will take the
default value as I showed you before.
With one line of code, one script inclusion,
you could have Houdini working right now in
Chrome Stable in the future Edge which I also
test these slides on, and they work, so that
was pretty cool.
I hope to see a lot more of this in the future.
It's a great way it that gives developers
so much control over the styles of our website.
So, you can combine all those things to make
layouts like this, and as Aga said, I do sing
songs for every intro to my podcast.
I thought I would end this with a little ditty.
Can I get some music?
[Electronic piano music].
I'm doing this for you all.
* Try bootstrap.
* Go to the website with Stylus.
* Even almost with native.
* First I'm so thankful.
* Thank you to web good morning.
I don't understand it, though.
* One taught me love.
* One taught me to build patience.
* Now my paint looks amazing.
* I've learned and I've shared.
* But please don't look at it.
* Changing tech is a habit.
* And to that I say.
* Thank you, next!
>> Thank you!
[Cheering and applause].